as TV audiences continue to fracture the
definition of a hit show is constantly
evolving with every success there's
always a clunker waiting to be axed some
critics feel that 2017 has brought some
of the worst shows in recent history
with that in mind we've rounded up the
eight worst shows of 2017 Emerald City
just a few years ago aprox reported on
five of vastly different Wizard of Oz TV
adaptations and development only one of
those made it to where Emerald City was
director Tarsem Singh's first foray into
television it was clear that NBC was
hoping for their own game of Thrones but
while Emerald City was both beautiful
and violent no amounts of singh's
signature special effects could
compensate for a weak storyline
according to The Hollywood Reporter the
silly merges with the violent fumbling
the tone on down the yellow brick road
which here is made of opium even it's
telecast featuring Adria our jonah
olivia jackson cohen and vincent
d'onofrio was not enough to keep
audiences interested with all those
effects the show couldn't have been
cheap which meant that low ratings
quickly doomed the 10 episode season
after premiering the show in January NBC
canceled Emerald City in May APB when
sci-fi satire APB premiered on Fox it
had a lot of potential the series took
aim at America's police state in the
making but it felt more like a comedy
than the drama it really needed to be
APB followed tech billionaire Gideon
Reeves played by Justin Kirk and
explored privately funded police forces
equipped with drones mobile apps and
tech gadgets however too much focus was
put on flashy technology leaving no room
for actual character development The
Hollywood Reporter called the show just
an empty one of the mill cops show it's
just stupid heavily relying on style
over substance APB buckled under its own
distorted morality earning a 35% rating
at Rotten Tomatoes it was cancelled
after 12 episodes taken NBC tried to tap
into a particular set of skills have
taken a prequel series to Liam Neeson's
popular film franchise but unfortunately
Neeson had nothing to do with the spy
drama I don't know who you are
Clive stand-ins stars as a young bride
else giving audiences a perspective into
the paths of Neeson's hardened espionage
agent regardless of his prequel status
taken was ultimately just a procedural
that struggled to live up to the kinetic
pacing and compelling action of the
movies that inspired it as The Hollywood
Reporter explained what taken actually
proves to be as a series is just another
NBC action drama in which a government
team faces a different limited threat
each week poor reviews aside taken
performed well enough
prompting NBC to order a season 2
according to Deadline only Jennifer
Beals and Standen will return which
means some well needed restructuring has
definitely taken place training day
while taken was renewed for a second
season the NBC CBS's small screen
adaptation of Antoine Fuqua his training
day it wasn't so lucky
coming in at 22 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes the show was plagued with
horrible reviews as soon as it premiered
vulture called the Shoah hackneyed
dreadfully written carbon copy of every
crummy cop show you've ever seen
flipping the script in the 2001 films
original story the series paired rookie
Kyle Craig played by Justin Cornwell
with seasoned officer Frank rock played
by Bill Paxton it was an intriguing but
risky move for CBS who relied mostly on
Paxton's acting chops to carry the
series but Paxton's talents couldn't
save training day from overuse
exposition and slow pace the show is at
risk as soon as it premiered and after
Paxton's untimely passing in February TV
Line reported that it was moved from its
Thursday night timeslot to Saturday
deadline then reported that training day
was officially cancelled months later
star due to the massive success of
Empire Fox brought another hip-hop
themed drama from oscar-nominated
director Lee Daniels to the small screen
but audiences quickly discovered star
was nothing like the network's lavish
lion family drama the series follows a
melodramatic aspirations of star Davis
as she aims to get famous or die trying
with scandalous stories abound star
might not have been granted a second
season without big-name talent like
Benjamin Bratt and Queen Latifah
the one-dimensional characters cheesy
storylines and over-the-top music video
segments make it difficult to take star
seriously the guilty pleasure angle may
be the show's selling point setting up
star is a fun chaser to the more
Empire according to variety a two-hour
crossover between the two shows helped
boost our second season ratings but only
time will tell if it will make it to a
third season disjointed Chuck Lorre
knows a thing or two about sitcom
success bringing two and a Half Men and
the Big Bang Theory to CBS two comedies
that were regularly panned by critics
while still garnering huge ratings
moving from Network TV to Netflix his
streaming platform Laurie has continued
doing a thing with the pot comedy
disjointed the show stars Kathy Bates as
Ruth whitefeather Feldman the owner of
an offbeat medical marijuana dispensary
in Los Angeles and used Larese signature
3 camera setup to explore the
misadventures of the shop staff The
Daily Dot reported just as real nerds
tend to reject the heights in the shrill
versions of themselves they see on the
Big Bang Theory real pot smokers are
likely to reject or even be offended by
their portrayal on disjointed this
series maybe summer 2007 teens weirdest
new show according to The Wrap it was
also the summer's worst marvel's iron
fist Marvel and Netflix have proven to
be a worthy partnership over the past
few years from daredevil to Jessica
Jones fans had grown accustomed to AG
comic book stories mixed with a heaping
helping of action and intrigue that all
came to a halt with Marvel's iron fist
the conflict came slow the fight
sequences fell flat and Finn Jones's
performance as Danny ran 2 failed to
live up to expectations
Jessica hammocks portrayal of Colleen
winger breathed some much-needed life
into the series but it wasn't enough to
lift iron fists out of the muck
indieWIRE said the series felt
incredibly in essential even boring at
times it just didn't need to happen
Marvel could have taken a pass on this
one or found a more interesting take on
it Entertainment Weekly reports that a
second season is underway promising a
full-on comic style team-up between
Danny Rand and Luke Cage he is hoping
their partnership can lift the series
out of the Netflix doldrums
marvels and humans scoring just ten
percent on Rotten Tomatoes and humans
comes in as Marvel's worst ever
comic-book adaptation indieWIRE Kordich
quote the worst thing Marvel has done in
decades a PC bug this series with the
Disney budget and even gave it an IMAX
limited theatrical release but not even
the star power of ansan mounts and the
yuan rayons seem to help box office mojo
reports just 2.9 million dollars in
ticket sales for the theatrical release
and TV series finale reports the show
averaged just under 2 million viewers in
this case however poor reviews and
dismal viewership might not lead to a
cancellation Marvel's original plan for
Inhumans called for a big-screen MCU
blockbuster so Disney might still
greenlight more episodes on ABC's behalf
on the bright side if more seasons do
come at least we'll get to see more of
that Q giant dog thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]